governor jon corzine got her a great
state of New Jersey I think there's no
avoiding that the major issue that is
going to impact everyone's life in
America is the economy have to get that
stabilized we have to get it out of free
fall into a position where it begins to
recover and so all decisions I think in
the short run have to be focused on
trying to get our economy going so that
our people our citizens can restore
their confidence in the direction of the
country can never walk away from our
responsibilities in the international
arena we have two wars a hundred and
sixty thousand troops in harm's way as
we sit here at this moment in time so it
can't take the take his eye off of our
international responsibilities in it in
fact it links back to our economy
because if we were able to thoughtfully
and carefully bring some of our troops
home and have a less lessened investment
in some of the things that we're doing
in our overseas operations it would help
our economy at home so I think he has to
give that great effort and then I think
you know the the overall issue with
regard to our energy independence and
protecting the globe from the build-up
of carbon all of those issues come
together
I think we have to get focused on the
real economy on the basic elements of
housing markets financing markets in
general so that credit begins to flow
first thing I probably be doing is ask
the President to make sure that we
changed our bankruptcy laws so that
there could be renegotiation of
mortgages between the lender and
borrower you know organized in some
straightforward way second thing I'd be
pushing to make sure that we were
finding the way to put money into
keeping people in their homes either
direct loans to the individuals so they
continue to make payments or a
restructuring of the loans themselves
the fact is we won't stabilize the
wholesale financing markets the that
toxic products that have been created on
leverage CDOs the kinds of things that
people have talked about in the
mortgage-backed security market that are
causing thanks so much problem unless we
actually stabilize the underlying
housing market in the mortgage market
that is a part of that
first thing you have to do any time you
have a tough situation is talk openly
and frequently with the audience that is
going to be the receiver of the changes
that you have to take or make to address
the problem you need to make sure that
you're fully in communication about what
the nature the problem is and what it is
that you believe you need to be doing
and that needs to be very clear and you
need to be repeating that over and over
again as far and broadly as you can so
that people understand what is impacting
their lives I think actually
communications a lot of it but also not
avoiding the problem you just have to go
at it and the tougher it gets the more
you have to be direct at addressing the
problem because if you don't there's a
cumulative momentum to the sort of
negative patterns that develop whether
it's in business or whether it's in
government and economics
you